[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire comment limiter le pouvoir
des géants du numérique à
l'international que ce soit les gars
femmes américain où les bété x chinois
comment établir une souveraineté
numérique européenne comment fixer nos
propres règles nos propres normes
faut-il créer une instance de
gouvernance numérique mais comment et
avec qui les américains les chinois ni
l'un ni l'autre les européens restant
numériquement non-alignés pour débattre
de tout cela nous avons invité à ce mal
à vous enseigner les enjeux éthiques de
l'économie numérique à sciences po ainsi
qu'à le scp europe
vous avez publié dans le monde une
tribune appelant l'union européenne à
mettre en place une gouvernance
numérique commune avec les états unis
alors ça voudrait dire que vous pensez
qu'ils établir une une souveraineté
numérique européenne est possible elle
est possible sous un certain nombre de
conditions déjà de définir ce qu'on
entend par là la souveraineté qui est un
concept aux contours très flous
aujourd'hui qui sert un certain nombre
d'agendas et de comprendre surtout que
c'est d'abord un sujet politique et de
modèle de société et donc la proposition
d'avoir une coque gouvernance
transatlantique c'est plutôt d'essayer
d'impulser une instance un endroit où on
peut parler de ses modèles idéologique
politique quand on a un échiquier
géopolitique qui vont apparaître
aujourd'hui de grandes forces que sont
les états unis et la chine est donc
toute la question c'est de
positionnement de l'europe
la danse dont sur 7/7 recompositions
géopolitiques
jonathan bourguignon vous êtes
entrepreneur et consultant dans le
numérique vous venez de publier aux
éditions divergences internet tf1 et 0
de la silicon valley à la chine n'est
censé mutation du réseau alors même
question est-ce que vous pensez que
d'établir une souveraineté numérique
européenne est possible et à quelles
conditions
oui je pense que je vais avoir une
réponse assez similaire à celle d'asma
il ya il ya trois niveaux
je dirais dans la souveraineté numérique
un qui est un niveau de sécurité qui est
ce dont on parle beaucoup en ce moment
quand on parle de cloud souverain un
autre qui est de compétitivité
technologique qui est probablement assez
mal d'adressé dans ces mêmes débats mais
surtout le grand absent du débat c'est
la question de la vision politique que
servirait en fait effectivement internet
une souveraineté numérique
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord en europe sur cette
vision je peux être plus de doute mais
j'imagine que ce débat va nous aider à
répondre et espérons le
thomas forêt vous avez fondé ou à leur
réseau social français que l'on présente
comme un anti facebook parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus étanche et qu'ils
n'utilisent pas les données personnelles
de ses utilisateurs
dans une tribune parue dans le jdd vous
plaidiez vous pour que l'union
européenne un quart d'une troisième voie
un alignement numérique entre les gars
femmes américains et les bateyes chinois
donc c'est vous pensez vous qu'une une
souveraineté numérique européenne est
possible oui elle est possible d'autant
plus qu enfin voila si elle n'était pas
possible moi je ne serai pas
entrepreneur aujourd'hui elle est
possible non seulement mais elle est
nécessaire surtout la souveraineté
numérique au delà de la technologie
c'est d'abord la souveraineté tout court
c'est l'idée de retrouver notre destin
nous européens sur les outils que nous
utilisons sur les industries que nous
développons et évidemment qu'elle est
possible en ce sens qu internet n'en est
qu'à l'âge de pierre à internet ça à 30
ans donc vous voyez tout est possible et
je pense
ce que le génie européen sera être à la
hauteur à la hauteur des enjeux des
enjeux qui sont la défense de ces
valeurs depuis toujours
ophélie coelho vous êtes chercheuse
indépendante en géopolitique du
numérique membre du conseil scientifique
de l'institut rousseau sur les questions
relatives à la géopolitique du numérique
pensez vous qu'une souveraineté
numérique européenne est possible et à
quelles conditions
alors oui ils sont l'un ténue méric
européenne est possible je dirais comcom
a tué juste avant moi quel est vraiment
souhaitable même un nécessaire pour que
nous puissions en fait dans une position
de force pour négocier aussi dans ce
domaine là puisque aujourd'hui on se
retrouve quand même avec des objets
technologiques enfin des entreprises
technologiques qui ont un pouvoir de
négociation énorme et devant lequel nous
sommes nous sommes quand même assez
impuissant aujourd'hui et donc nous
devons en fait conquérir bâtir je dirais
même plutôt une sorte d'indépendance
numérique plutôt que alors une
souveraineté numérique indépendance
numérique aux autos mais stratégique et
oui on en a besoin
après pour le faire il ya plusieurs
façons de le faire
il est oui il va falloir se mettre
d'accord une des choses il va aussi
falloir soutenir très clairement à tout
un tissu industriel qui aujourd'hui
existe un qu'il est performant il ya des
compétences dans lequel on ne suis pas
assez confiante face élus fainéants des
tués le juridique en est une autre
le normatif en est une autre cible en
tout cas on a vraiment beaucoup d'outils
pour y parvenir
maintenant c'est aussi un choix
politique et c'est un courage politique
à avoir pour pouvoir pourquoi on sait
dans ce sens alors ça serait quoi là la
souveraineté numérique pour vous à ce
moment là elle faisait la nuance felli
coelho avec l'indépendance c'est quoi la
souveraineté numérique après tarbes
enfin le monde la veut mais de quoi
s'agit-il exactement
l'une des questions les hypothèses de
départ sait de quoi est ce qu'on parle
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend
beaucoup la façon dont le sujet est pris
par le politique c'est de
parler d'autonomie stratégiques ou de
liberté de choix récemment encore ça a
été de dire que c'était du leadership en
vérité peu importe la terminologie au
fond la question c'est la question de
l'autodétermination des peuples sans
doute d'avoir des technologies qu'ils
soient au service d'un certain nombre de
valeurs d'un modèle de société dont il
faudrait débattre d' avoir la latitude
et la possibilité d'imposer ses règles
là ces normes la et et l'enjeu ce que ce
qu'expliquait je crois que j'en attends
tout à l'heure c'est un enjeu économique
évidemment c'est à dire d'avoir des
infrastructures sur lesquels on peut
avoir dix ont la main et surtout on n'en
a pas encore parlé mais c'est la
question des données personnelles c'est
à dire que un des gros sujets
aujourd'hui qui est un peu hystériser le
débat sur la question de la souveraineté
numérique c'est qu'en fait on est
absolument dépendant des des
infrastructures informationnel american
gars femmes en tête mais pas que et que
aujourd'hui depuis 2018 qu'il ya quelque
chose qui s'appelle cloud acquis en
taxant fait américain et qui permet aux
agences et et au gouvernement américain
en fait d'avoir accès aux données
personnelles qui sont hébergés par des
acteurs américains
quelle que soit leur localisation donc
en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'extraterritorialité du droit et qui
donc nous rend absolument vulnérables a
priori théoriquement dans les faits
c'est pas aussi évident est pas aussi
systématique que ça mais en tout cas il
y à sevrey ce vrai sujet là la deuxième
la deuxième
la deuxième question qui me chagrine et
un tout petit peu plus sur la question
de la souveraineté c'est que très vite
c'est devenu un marché
ce qu'on appelle un go to market sur ces
questions là et donc de ce point de vue
là il ya eu une volonté abandonné 2 de
vouloir qui a été courte de d'encourager
des entreprises
disons locales à l'échelle mondiale donc
les entreprises françaises et puis on se
rend compte que
au fur et à mesure des décisions qui
t'ont prêts qui ont été prises le gaia x
le cloud ii souverain de confiance et
cetera que la doctrine n'est pas encore
fixée en tout cas la vision politique
aujourd'hui en tout cas en france est
globalement toujours très néo libérale
est axé sur les questions de
performances donc qu'on s'est retrouvé
très vite dans ce dilemme performance
avec des solutions américaine qui sont
vraiment sophistiqués pour le coup
objectivement et bien comme ils disent
qu on a un écosystème d'innovation qui
soit relativement bon
aujourd'hui sur toute la surcouche
logicielle dia etc
on l'a vu avec la question du reste data
robe objectivement il y à des
fonctionnalités aujourd'hui une des
services aujourd'hui qu'ils ne peuvent
être produits que par des acteurs
américains
à ce niveau de sophistication donc on
s'est retrouvé dans ce dilemme où
l'exécutif s'est retrouvé dans ce
dilemme entre performance maximisation
de la performance logique traîneau
libéral en fait
et ben compétitivité du tissu économique
français et donc qu'ils ont fait espèce
de choix entre deux à dire bah en fait
on va complètement neutralisé des
questions d'extraterritorialité du droit
en commercialisant les solutions
américaine mais via finalement des
acteurs français et enfin la dette le
dernier élément de réponse c'est que
l'autre chose moi qui peux me qui peut
le chagriner encore un tout petit peu
c'est le fait qu'on est très vite
restreint la question de la souveraineté
a simplement la question technique du
cloud or je le répète c'est vraiment une
question politique c'est une question
idéologique c'est une question de choix
de société et la question de la
souveraineté n'est pas que être ou ne
pas être un cloud heure française c'est
aussi la question des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui toute la question de la
désinformation de la de l'autonomie
démocratique en tout cas où de la
vivacité démocratique
quand on a des plateformes
essentiellement américaines qui sont
capables de bannir des hommes politiques
on a eu tout le scandale cambridge
analytica et ses poses la question de la
souveraineté alors non pas de l'état
mais des peuples
jonathan bourguignon la souveraineté ce
serait quoi
pour rebondir sur sur ce que vient de
dire asma donc cette souveraineté au
niveau des hauts niveaux de jeu ne suis
pas sûr d'être d'accord avec avec ce qui
vient de se dire sur la sophistication
des plateformes et le fait qu'on n'ait
pas une économie qui puisse qu'il puisse
répondre à la demande de que serait ce
cloud à tabou ou le sait la belle ces
labels numérique on a des entreprises
qui sont capables de produire du cloud
on a des en france on a des au vih ont à
l'escale ouais on a des éclaireurs cloud
la question de ce label c'est que on
donne on l'administration si j'ai bien
suivi ce dossier a décidé de donner un
label dans un temps extrêmement court à
des solutions qui se porteraient
volontaires pour migrer tout une partie
de l'infrastructure des administrations
et les données uniquement aux
entreprises qui ont ce label faire le
choix d'aller aussi vite sur ces
questions là c'est en fait faire le
choix de ne pas donner la possibilité à
des entreprises plus petites que les
gaffes à de créer une offre qui
répondrait à la demande saas est
extrêmement problématique parce que
effectivement si on si on choisit
d'aller sur un cloud ibm le cloud ibm va
venir avec un ensemble d'outils
d'intelligence artificielle comme comme
comme le souligne asma comme watson par
exemple si la dépense publique
on décide en amont qu'elle ne va pas
servir à venir nourrir à l'innovation
technologique française c'est sûr que on
ne pourra pas développer derrière des
solutions dit la française
qui sont en compétition avec watson est
en fait cette compte cette question va
bien au delà de juste une question de
cloud le cloud c'est un type
d'infrastructure des données à ce même
mentionner les réseaux sociaux les
services tous les services qui
produisent de la donne et qui sont
américains on peut aller plus bas aussi
il ya aussi les technologies du réseau
les réseaux eux mêmes les les
les couches qui fournissent le réseau
les gros tuyaux parce que internet
jusqu'à présent c'est essentiellement
des gros tuyaux c'est en train de
devenir aussi des flotte satellitaire
produites par l'américain sterling ou
par amazon et son projet kuypers est en
fait la souveraineté numérique ne peut
pas se restreindre à regarder un petit
bout de l'infrastructure qui dans le cas
dans le cas dont on parle a assuré le
cloud à regarder un petit bout de ce que
signifie la souveraineté numérique qui
serait lutter contre l'extrême l'extra
territorialité des données il faut
regarder ça comme un ensemble plus grand
est dans une dynamique beaucoup plus
large et si on veut enfin si on veut
approfondir sur cette question des
infrastructures et de la place
croissante que son empreinte en train de
prendre les gaffes à sur cette
infrastructure alors qu'il venait de la
couche des services qui descendent peu à
peu je pense que vous devriez interroger
ophélie qui vient de publier une note
très très complète pour l'institut
rousseau sur le sujet d'aidés alors
ophélie oui tout à fait alors justement
c'est vrai que moi je suis très surprise
quand on parle de d'autodétermination et
qu'à côté de ça on parle d'alliance
transatlantique pour la simple et bonne
raison qu une alliance transatlantique
en fait c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on est
extrêmement dépendant des services
étasunien alors après on peut dire
plutôt qu'on ait des clients pour le
pour une colonie numérique des états
unis dit clairement on peut le dire
comme ça qu'on en parle peut-être une
détermination ça voudrait dire qu'on ne
saurait pas dépendante du coût
d'infrastructure à la fois logiciel ou
socle or aujourd'hui les gars fiable
comme moi j'aime bien plutôt à pied les
big tech 1 ou par de plus en plus
importante sur les infrastructures comme
les câbles sous marins par exemple les
câbles sous-marins c'est plus de 90% de
l'activité numérique aujourd'hui un ca
passe pas par le ciel ça passe bien
parlé
et dans cette industrie du câble sous
marin
au départ les acteurs traditionnels par
exemple c'est les télécommunications et
les états aujourd'hui ce sont les gammes
ce sont les grecs se sont longuement
microsoft d'une certaine façon assive
facebook et amazon qui construit de leur
propre câble aujourd'hui on est sur une
dimension est très différente de celle
de simple fournisseur de services
logiciels
même chose pour les infrastructures du
constellation satellitaire tout à
l'heure justement il nous parlait du
coup de gay d'aidé constellation
satellitaire du projet qui part d'amazon
est aujourd'hui en fait quand on regarde
ce qui se passe au kursaal au niveau des
technologies cloud
en fait microsoft google amazon
construisent l'infrastructure logicielle
qui est relié en fait assez
constellation satellitaire
donc en fait ils sont en train de
prendre une place bien bien plus
importante que celle qu'ils avaient
aujourd'hui et qu'il se passe c'est que
nos acteurs proches les télécoms par
exemple que ce soit orange ou d'autres
acteurs de telekom en allemagne au fonds
des partenariats stratégiques avec des
entreprises pour gérer les réseaux
saljic
donc on rentre dans une autre dimension
aujourd'hui de dépendances donc quand on
nous parle d'auto détermination et coupa
ans d'alliance transatlantique
on a quelque chose en fait n'est
absolument pas cohérent qui était totale
qui s'opposent entre-temps on peut pas
parler de souveraineté numérique
si à côté de ça on parle de d'alliance
transatlantique je pense qu'on va on va
certainement en parler et quand on parle
aussi d'alliance transatlantique
en fait on en dise quoi on vise un
ennemi qui serait un ennemi commun qui
serait ce cette rhétorique du péril
jaune
je m'arrête là parce qu'on va sûrement
on va revenir et sur l'alliance
transatlantique et sur les chinois et
même sur les russes si vous en avez vous
envie mais question pour thomas forêt
c'est la suite de ce débat et notamment
sur la souveraineté numérique
ces géants du numérique et notamment les
gars femmes ce qui respecte
est-ce qu'ils sont seulement compatible
avec la souveraineté numérique alors que
ce soit de l'europe et même y compris
des
des états unis quand il s'agit des gars
femme ou de la chine quand il s'agit des
pea tic
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir à la fois des
géants du numérique tactile en existe
aujourd'hui ces géants là et la
souveraineté des états qu' ils soient
européens ou pas alors c'est une très
bonne question mind semble
qu'effectivement c'est en tout cas les
béatex et les gars façon vraiment deux
sujets très différents
il me semble que du côté américain les
gaffes à échappe à la souveraineté
étasunienne puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de procédures qui sont
qui commence à devenir au sénat
américain
et il me semble que les gaffes à son
arrivée à une taille en fait et à une
puissance qui font d'elle en fait non
plus des entreprises mais maintenant des
néo états c'est-à-dire des des
organismes que nous ne connaissons pas a
certes sous droit privé mais qui
aujourd'hui ont une influence politique
économique on a été même jusqu'à avec
facebook imaginer une monnaie
indépendante
bon finalement ça n'aide pas tu toujours
pas fait mais enfin on verra de quoi
l'avenir sera fait et effectivement il
ya un vrai sujet même vis-à-vis des
américains
ses gaffes à ces grandes entreprises du
numérique échappe clairement au contrôle
démocratique qui serait légitime d'avoir
pour c'est pour ces entreprises
du côté des baies à thé xx du côté
chinois c'est évidemment différent
puisque on voit qu'il ya un contrôle
beaucoup plus forts de de l'état et
c'est évidemment un régime que qu'on
souhaite absolument pas pour nos
territoires et on peut - on se retrouve
moins dans ce modèle bien entendu ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas nous les
européens c'est que cette souveraineté
elle nous échappe totalement
moi c'est vrai que je vous écoute et
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'attention asma
vous avez évoqué un sujet très important
c'est cet aspect intime en politique de
vision politique qui manque cruellement
à nos décideurs européens aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'effectivement il faut
que nous réussissions à construire une
puissance en europe par seulement en
france en allemagne en espagne et c'est
à m'aimer mais véritablement une
politique de souveraineté numérique
mais comme il est difficile de se dire
on a déjà loupé les premières
moi je crois que c'est ça le un des
sujets qui nous empêche d'avoir cette
politique numérique aujourd'hui on se
dit sans cesse on va être les meilleurs
sur l'intelligence artificielle
puis après on se dit on va être les
meilleurs sur la bloque chaîne puis
maintenant on se dit on va être les
meilleurs sur l'info sur le cantique
en réalité je pense que tout ça manque
de vision long terme
alors est-ce que c'est dû au fait que
les mandats sont extrêmement courts
maintenant auprès de nos dirigeants
peut-être un mais ce qu'il faudrait
c'est à mon sens se dire que il faut
arrêter d'essayer de rattraper le retard
il faut essayer de construire et nous
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire nous les
entrepreneurs c'est de dire on rebâtit à
zéro on rebâtit à 0 des infrastructures
ont rebâti à 0 du logiciel et je pense
que l'âme alors évidemment moi je ne
pouvais pas m'exprimer au nom de de gens
qui gèrent du des infrastructures ou ou
du réseau purement mais n'est en tout
cas le logiciel je crois que c'est le
grand oublié en réalité de la dite
stratégie qui nous a été proposé par le
gouvernement sur ce cloud de confiance
alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas s'il
défie temps on l'a dit d'héberger des
données sécurisées au sein de
l'infrastructure hébergé en france mais
on nous dit que c'est le logiciel
américain qui va primer et ça c'est un
grand problème parce que c'est tiré un
trait sur l'ensemble de ceux qui font
aujourd'hui du software du logiciel en
france en europe et qui sont voilà tout
simplement oublié de cette stratégie
moi je crois que là il ya beaucoup
évidemment beaucoup à faire dans dans
énormément de domaines parce que c'est
extrêmement large la souveraineté
numérique
mais le sujet du logiciel est important
il faut absolument pas que ce soit un
sujet oublié
il ya des grandes forces en europe qui
sont dans le logiciel notamment est à
mon sens il faut rebâtir puisqu'on n'a
pas été capable de bâtir à nouveau enfin
voila depuis le départ ces technologies
qui aujourd'hui sont outre atlantique ou
en asie asma ballard des genres du
numérique ce qui sont compatibles avec
l'idée même de
de souveraineté numérique y compris dans
leur propre pays
alors je vais vous répondre je vais
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit il n'y a
absolument pas d'incohérence ou de
contradiction entre le fait d'installer
des instances de gouvernance
transatlantique et d'avoir une forme
d'auto détermination d'une part et d'une
souveraineté numérique
je suis restée tout court d'autre part
et pourquoi parce que c'est pas tant de
dire péril jaune ou à les méchants
américains c'est pas tant d'être dans
ses réflexions binaire que te dire qu'on
a des intérêts stratégiques
par construction de l'europe vers l'est
vers les états unis avec les états unis
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
le produit de l'histoire du 20e siècle
et de ce qui s'est passé
d'une part que d'autre part le modèle
idéologique au techno idéologique des
chinois n'est absolument pas au regard
de nos valeurs en tout cas désirable
parce que ça donne quoi ça donne en fait
de la techno surveillance de masse en
gros si je schématise crédit social etc
donc et la difficulté qu'on a eu c'est
que en fait par défaut de réflexion
politique par défaut de réflexion et de
vision sur ces sujets là en fait on est
rentré dans une forme de 2 da proches
très grégaire et en fait on s'est mis à
installer de la même façon sans le dire
sans l'assumer tout à fait de la
reconnaissance faciale à quadriller
l'espace public
sous prétexte de l'ennemi invisible
terrorisme les menaces diverses et
variées donc de toute façon il ya une
urgence à repenser encore une fois je le
répète et j'insiste le modèle de société
et donc peu importe qu'on en capsules
s'assure une instance de gouvernance
transatlantiques et peut importe le nom
qu'on lui donne l'idée derrière et de se
dire qu'est ce qu'on en fait qu'est ce
qu'on met dedans quels le contenu de ces
réflexions là et donc le contenu ne
s'est pas de dire on va faire à iso
comme aujourd'hui c'est à dire une
commission européenne qui bon avec
l'arrivée de thierry breton il ya un
certain nombre de dévolution dans la
doctrine ou en tout cas dans la
compréhension des modèles économiques
mais qui ne va pas jusqu'au bout de
l'idée
typiquement le paquet législatif des ca
des mâts de l'année d'un
hier en fait disons que à lui enclenche
une avancée mais ne va pas au bout des
sujets qui sont les modèles économiques
et les modèles technologiques qui sont
sous-jacents au ghana et au bik tech en
tout cas ce qu'on appelle les
plateformes structurantes
donc ça c'est le premier point et moi ce
que je dis en tout cas c'est qu'il est
assez urgent car m'en donner ou
commencent à se parler avec les états
unis
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a vu que la
reverb hayden avait enclenché un certain
nombre de 2,2 de nouveautés en tout cas
dans leur propre rapport aux gaffes à
qui est très complexe qui est très
ambigu parce que jusque là en fait il
était absolument de mèche
enfin il était en tout cas sur un
continuum fonctionnel pour installer des
dispositifs en tout cas de captation de
données maximale de surveillance et en
fait on sait parfaitement le maître
c'est à dire que ça a vraiment commencé
après le 11 septembre
et donc ça a été des programmes
d'ailleurs qui ont été soutenues par la
darpa
donc il ya ça et puis depuis quelque
temps en tout cas depuis son arrivée
mais pas tellement par amour des valeurs
démocratiques que par tension de son
économie domestique et des difficultés
qu'il a en fait commencé à se dire bah
en fait tout ce qui est anti trust
thomas thomas thomas l'évoquait toutes
les toutes les actions qui a eu les
nominations à la halle à l'autorité de
la concurrence américaine avec des
professeurs économie ses droits de la
columbia qui sont plutôt réputé pour
être sur des lignes assez radical par
rapport aux gaffes a abandonné lisabeth
warren qui évoquait le démantèlement des
gars femmes
bon donc en fait aux etats-unis c'est un
peu le pharmakon c'est à dire que vous
avez un peu le poison est le remède en
tout cas dans la sphère académique et
c'est c'est ça c'est vers ça en tout cas
qu'il faut tendre et c'était ça aussi
l'objet de ma tribune c'est de dire
qu'en fait il se passe aujourd'hui des
choses dans la sphère politique
académique américains qui sont très
intéressants à regarder sur lesquels
l'europe a tout intérêt à s'amarrer pour
faire avancer sa et donc avancé sa le ça
c'est quoi c'est le statut juridique de
ces plats tombe c'est le statut
juridique des données personnelles
c'est c'est de se dire quel est le
malentendu qu'on a vu sur les nouvelles
technologies et quelles technologies
on peut aujourd'hui m
place comme le fait thomas à son échelle
par exemple mais quelle technologie ou
quelle conception de soc technologique
on peut mettre en place qui soit au
service de notre vision du monde et pas
l inverse
donc en fait la tribu ou house que je ce
que je raconte de dedans pardon c'est
plutôt de dire parlons nous et puis il
ya de toute façon urgence à ce que l'on
garde une forme chez nous en tout cas en
europe de leadership normatif et je
trouve que même là dessus on est mise en
difficulté par les états unis
quand il a fait sa tournée récemment
baden est là clairement explicité le
fait que aujourd'hui l'enjeu par rapport
à lâcher c'était bien une course
idéologique et non pas technologique et
donc normative et or jusqu'à présent
l'europe étaient plutôt réputés on l'a
vu avec leur gpd etc comme étant un peu
le fer de lance de c2c de ces aspects là
juridique et de droit international donc
l'idée c'est de garder au moins cette
force-là comme axe différenciant plus
par ailleurs la question du marché
unique est un vrai un vrai actif pour
pour l'heure pour peser après je
terminerais là dessus là où thomas a
aussi raison c'est que toute la question
de la souveraineté c'est de se dire à
quelle souveraineté est ce que c'est un
souverainisme d'un repli sur soi ou est
ce que c'est une souveraineté solidaire
dont on redéfinit les contours et à
partir de là quelle échelle d'action et
l'échelle d'action et les triples et les
locales et nationales
puis elle est globale on fait une pause
on reprend ce débat
[Musique]
assiste-t-on à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est simplement une place de
plus en plus prépondérante de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les prêts garantis par
l'état et c'est fait
l'état se paye les entreprises l'état
pourrait devenir un partenaire un
actionnaire d'outré un très grand nombre
d'entreprises françaises
on a un peu dans une logique d'économie
de guerre où l'état a suppléé on va dire
à la défaillance du privé on est dans
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
soviétisation il est vrai que le
gouvernement n'avait aujourd'hui pas
d'autre moyen que de faire le poids
qu'il en coûte
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
qui va soutenir va va subir ça c'est
nous dans nos impôts
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution un
supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
pays puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement chinois en l'état actuel
des capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terres rares il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
repenser débat sur la souveraineté
numérique européenne avec un smala avec
jonathan bourguignon thomas forêt et
ophélie coelho johnathan bangui l'union
est ce que vous pensez comme bâle smala
qu'il faut créer une instance une
instance de gouvernance on verra après
avec qui mais est-ce que déjà on a
besoin de cela on a besoin d'instances
de gouvernance pour internet il ya des
instances qui existe l'internet society
par exemple qui qui est déjà une
instance qui réunit des gouvernements
des organisations des entreprises qui
est la maison mère de l'internet
engineering task force en charge de
décrire tous les protocoles internet et
c'est déjà une organisation à laquelle
la chine et d'autres régimes reproche
d'être beaucoup trop atlantiste
donc je serais assez curieux de de
savoir qu'il faudrait créer comme comme
instances différentes de celles après
parmi les choses qu'on contient entendre
on a mentionné l'écosystème l'écosystème
internet chinois avec ses bêtes et x et
son concept de souveraineté qu'elle est
allée appliqué très loin on a mentionné
leur gpd aussi c'est intéressant d'avoir
mentionné ces deux là parce que tout le
débat
le les termes de souveraineté numérique
en fait viennent de là autour d'eux au
tour de 2012 en france puis en europe on
a commencé à parler de souveraineté
numérique et ça s'est transmis ça s'est
traduit par la mise en place de ce
règlement général pour la protection des
données
qui visait qui interprétait la notion de
souveraineté numérique comme les données
de citoyens européens doivent être logés
en europe et doivent être sous contrôle
des utilisateurs avec du coup tout un
tas de deux interfaces qui se sont mis à
polluer depuis quelques années à vos
écrans ou chaque fois vous visitez un
site web on vous demandait ce que vous
consentez ce que vous consentez pas vous
le redemande
dix fois et c'est donc est ce que le s
que leur gpd bien implémenté ou pas ne
rentrons pas dans ce débat en tout cas
le rg a prouvé que si l'europe
voulait imposer à des entreprises
américaines dont le maître mot c'est
celle à la non friction de leur
interface un service absolument parfait
dans lesquelles elles et les
utilisateurs ne quitte jamais le site
web on peut perturber leur expérience
comme ça l'europe a réussi à le faire
la chine peut être vu aussi de manière
très très cynique comme une bonne
nouvelle parce que j'ai entendu
l'europe est trop en retard pour pour m
mettre à jour son économie numérique ces
technologies numériques
je pense que l'europe est pas aussi en
retard technologiquement que l'était la
chine ya 20 ans sauf que en 20 ans en
déclarant de manière très nette
ce que la chine voulait faire avec son
internet et l'internet chinois est
véritablement à l'image de ce que le
parti communiste chinois veut faire de
sa société si vous vous référez à tout
un tas de systèmes
politiques communautaires qui ont été
mis en place depuis la révolution
culturelle avec les roues chaos qui sont
qui sont des des dossiers familiaux de
planification urbaine avec le d'organes
qui est une espèce de fichiers de
l'individu qui le suit toute sa vie qui
inclut les notes qui reçoit l'école les
notes que lui met les ses employeurs etc
qui est du coup extrêmement proche de l'
effusion peut fantasmer qu'on a de ce
qu'est le système de crédit social
la chine a réussi à mettre en place un
internet
utopique à sa manière qui n'avait rien à
voir avec ce que déclarait avec que ce
que déclaré qu' internet devait être
pour les gaffes à la question de est ce
que cette souveraineté numérique
européenne doit être faite dans une
alliance transatlantique
est ce que pour reprendre le terme d'
assez mal de tout à l'heure la manière
dont les données personnelles sont gérés
par les gaffes à sont un malentendu jeu
ça me semble pas évident parce que si on
regarde si on regarde quelque chose de
très américain et de très européen comme
la santé la manière dont on gère
l'assurance maladie ou en europe de
manière très caricatural on a une
sécurité sociale
aux états unis on achète son assurance
santé
une assurance santé privée va vouloir
vous faire payer un premium
selon que vous êtes en bonne santé et
elle va récupérer ces indications de
toutes les manières possibles et ça
s'est matérialisé bien avant l'arrivée
d'internet par
par des notations de crédit par des
échanges de données entre banques
entre assurance entre plein d'entités
qui tenait des registres sur les
individus pour savoir si ça allait être
de bons payeurs ci serait en bonne santé
si etc
il me semble que toute l'économie des
données qui s'est mise en place à partir
de la bulle internet par dessus google
par-dessus facebook est très similaire à
ce qui existait déjà dans la société
américaine et n'était pas n'avait pas
lieu en france et avait été interdit en
france et c'est la raison pour laquelle
la cnil a été construite en 1978 parce
que un projet un peu similaire était sur
le point de voir le jour
donc pour résumer je me demande quels
seraient les modalités de cette
organisation transatlantique ce qu'elle
apporterait par rapport à l'internet
society et si les états unis comme seul
interlocuteur serait véritablement le
bon interlocuteur mettre en place notre
propre internet utopique dans la vision
européenne
c'est une question que je vous poserai
d'ailleurs dans un instant c'est qu'au
fond est-ce qui a tant de points communs
que cela entre les états unis et
l'europe c'est la question qui a l'air
de se poser jonathan bourguignon la
parole à à thomas forêt oui cette
alliance transatlantique effectivement à
ce m'a posé cette tribune qui pose
beaucoup de questions ce qui est
intéressant
voilà moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir un avis
trop c'est trop binaire parce que je
pense que ces débats il mérite d'être
élevé un tout petit peu 7
cette alliance en fait c'est quoi c'est
considérer ce que vous allez dire que
l'amérique les états unis c'est pas un
tout c'est d'abord les entreprises qui
la composent
les sénateurs les son gouvernement sa
politique
et effectivement il ya toujours un
intérêt à aller voilà travailler avec
nos alliés mais à mon sens il faudrait
pas oublier que ce sont nos alliés ne
sont pas ni des européens l'idée
français
et en réalité il faut jamais perdre à
l'esprit je pense que voilà nous
défendons nos intérêts ce qui est bien
légitime et les intérêts de nos enfants
et en matière économique politique
évidemment industriels et je pense qu
évidemment il faut pas faire black-out
sur sur les états unis s'est totalement
serait idiot de penser ça en revanche
dire que ces modèles européens et
américains sont des modèles qui sont
différents ça il faut clairement y
réfléchir on parle ici de culture en
réalité est ce qu'on a envie vous avez
parlé jonathan vous avez illustré avec
ce voilà le système de santé absolument
pas le même et aujourd'hui en france les
gens qui sont qui bénéficie système
français de santé évidemment se pose pas
la question de savoir s'ils sont en
bonne santé ou non voilà il ya quelque
chose d égalitaire ça c'est une des
particularités françaises
mais au-delà de ça oui je pense à des
exemples très concrets
vous avez eu pendant le confinement
peut-être ceux qui écoutent vous vous
même tout le monde
tout le monde a subi cette vague un peu
de solutions de visioconférence poteau
c'était sous une tente au 7 et eames
qu'elle était l'alternative pas
d'alternative et c'est ça le problème
est qu'ils qu'est ce que nous proposait
cet outil de microsoft ims il a proposé
très rapidement de pouvoir mesurer la
productivité des collaborateurs des
salariés dans le monde des entreprises
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il y
avait je crois un score de productivité
et et ça voulait dire que le manager
d'une équipe pouvait mesurer la
productivité de tous ses collaborateurs
en fonction de son utilisation de steam
est ce que vous imaginez un instant ce
que ça vous veut dire au delà de
microsoft s'est pas vraiment le problème
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que par
les outils numériques qui aujourd'hui
nous envahissent légitimement il
légitimement ça veut dire que ces outils
il façonne en fait notre façon de faire
notre façon de vivre pour les outils qui
sont communs voilà dans notre vie
personnelle façon de travailler pour ces
outils dont je vous parle et 7 façonne
il nous façonne à la façon américaine et
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas cette
vision là en europe et ça je crois que
ce qui est ce qui est fondamental
c'est au delà de la question de la
technologie en tant que tel c'est de
comprendre que cette technologie vous le
voyez bien chaque jour on a notre
téléphone notre smartphone en réalité sa
gouverne nos actions sa gouverne en fait
ça transforme notre façon d'être dans
notre façon de vivre et notre façon de
consommer si je vais jusqu'au bout
eh bien ces outils là ça mériterait un
tout petit instant qu'on réfléchisse à
ce qu'on pourrait faire nous en europe
qu'elles seraient des outils qui serait
européen comment comment serait-il bâti
serait-il juste des copies conformes de
ce cas aux etats-unis non je ne crois
pas évidemment il serait absolument pas
d'écho fil des copies conformes de ce
qui se passe en chine ça c'est clair
mais non plus américain vous voyez donc
je crois que l'enjeu de la souveraineté
numérique et de tous ces débats c'est
l'émergence en fait la résurgence
peut-être même de la culture européenne
et ce contre quoi nous nous battons et
pourquoi nous nous battons c'est la
liberté tout simplement vous savez le
mot souveraineté
en réalité on parle de souveraineté des
peuples c'est ce que vous avez dit asma
c'est la liberté des peuples
voilà et et si on parle alors pour
répondre à votre question c'est selon la
propos de la gouvernance
cette gouvernance allait elle est
nécessaire en europe déjà aidé à bâtir
en europe clairement et évidemment il
faut pas la faire en dehors du monde il
faut la faire avec nos alliés
historiques et en ce sens en ce sens
c'est seulement en ce sens oui je trouve
que des discussions ont transatlantiques
sont extrêmement intéressante alors
réponse de la spab à l'ail puis je
passerai la parole à philippe willow je
pense qu'en fait en vous écoutant en
écoutant tout ce qui vient d'être dit
évidemment je suis d'accord avec thomas
je pense aussi que raisonnablement on
pose tous le même diagnostic
le diagnostic c'est qu'on a un problème
d'indépendance technologiques politiques
et qu on a un problème de feuille de
route c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui par
défaut de vision politique la vision
politique qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire plutôt que de faire un cloud
souverain de confiance moi quand je
trouve absolument aberrant donc je pense
qu'on pose tous le même diagnostic
c'est à dire c'était de se dire en fait
et plutôt que de saupoudrer en fonction
des besoins d'aidé des modes du moment
tous nos fonds 1 milliard à gauche un
milliard à droite un coup c'est le
cantique un pouce il ya dans je ne sais
quoi et c'est un c'est de se dire
qu'elles sont vraiment sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement numérique
quelle politique industrielle numérique
on pose de façon claire sur les trente
prochaines années
ce qu'a fait la chine en fait est en
effet à la rattraper son retard de façon
fulgurante avec une vision très claire
en concentrant ses fonds là où c'était
absolument stratégique pour elle donc
mais par défaut et l autre chose aussi
pour aller aussi dans le sens de ce qui
a été dit c'est que en europe
aujourd'hui l'europe n'est pas un tout
l'europe les 27 pays aux intérêts
divergents et par rapport à macron sur
la question de l'autonomie stratégique
l'allemagne absolument pas du tout sur
la même ligne ni l'italie d'ailleurs
donc de toute façon cette phobie
américaine et franco française parce que
l'allemagne a priori pas le même niveau
de problèmes avec son autonomie
stratégique à l
hormis sur la question de la défense et
encore
et puis l'italie c'est encore plus c'est
encore plus neutre on va dire comme
rapport aux états unis à la question de
l'annulation d'un denim eric donc c'est
un débat qui est très français malgré
tout enfin en tout cas cette crispation
là et très française par l'histoire par
une forme de techno gaullisme c'est un
et donc la question
donc ça c'est ses premiers points le
deuxième point qu'est ce que j'entends
par vision politique donc c'est une
économie où une vision de politique
industrielle très clair avec des
investissements très clair avec des
fonds d'investissement pareilles
pratiques qui sont clairement identifiés
qui viennent soutenir les stratégies de
niche d'investissement plus
microprocesseurs biotech un peu importe
mais il faut absolument se dire et se
positionner là on a envie de se
positionner de façon à être
complémentaires mais à pouvoir aussi
pesé pour ça c'est pas du tout ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui par le personnel
politique
on n'y est pas du tout donc de deux
choses l'une soit on rêve à une
souveraineté dont aujourd'hui on n'a pas
les tenants et aboutissants soit on se
dit bas avec l'existant avec ce qu'on a
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer il se trouve qu'en
ce moment on a un alignement des
planètes avec bye donne donc pour des
raisons qui sont divergentes sans doute
mais il ya un chemin là pour penser des
choses et là où je suis d'accord aussi
c'est
en effet la question des données de
santé on va avoir une vision européenne
qui n'est absolument pas celle des états
unis
la question c'est pas de devenir des
clones la question c'est de trouver les
points de jonction entre administrations
par rapport à la gouvernance des gars va
et ce qui m'amène à mon dernier point
souveraineté et gouvernance ne sont pas
la même chose quand on parle de
souverainté numérique c'est comment
est-ce qu'on développe un écosystème
d'innovation local avec la commande
publique par exemple avec moi je le vois
sur sur les tous les sujets smartcity
sur sur les dimensions les collectivités
locales pousse vraiment aujourd'hui des
solutions souveraine local qu'ils soient
absolument pas du tout gigantesque donc
contrairement au mode un peu
monopolistique des gaffes à aider des
plateformes américaines en tout cas les
grandes
donc c'est pas ces panneaux rehaussé il
ya vraiment des choses qui sont en train
de se passer sur le terrain et qu'ils
sont plutôt positives en ce sens
maintenant c'est du bottom up c'est à
dire que ça va ça vient vraiment d'en
bas et que derrière c'est pas c'est pas
suivi par la couche et la strate
étatique il ya la commission européenne
qui essaie aussi de faire bouger des
choses sur la question de la norme g
revient et donc c'est là où il faut
jouer sur la question de 2 du leadership
un peu normatif le marché unis et but
d'une forme de marché unique mais
attention à ne pas confondre gouvernance
des gaffes a donc de fait
de fait aujourd'hui on est dépendant
involontairement volontairement par
vision politique ou pas peu importe mais
de fait on est dépendant de ses
infrastructures là donc comment est ce
qu'on fait pour les réguler au mieux
tout en développement une forme de
souveraineté nationale ou régionale mais
dont on doit aussi trouver les
articulations mais rester entre soi
comme ça aa voir port d'à peu près tout
ça va pas être une solution non plus
tenable le plus du vélo
oui alors oui en effet l'idée c'est pas
d'avoir peur ni de faire peur que ce
soit pour contrôler gars femmes contre
la chine ou la russie
peu importe c'est pas la question il ya
quelque chose quand même je reviens sur
l'identité internationale
évidemment que
le guide est d'une entité internationale
est intéressante différemment de celle
qui existe aujourd'hui pour le coup je
seulement 13 atlantique à l'atlantis
mais dans ce cas là ça veut dire qu'on
intègre tout le monde
une entité internationale ce serait une
idée de gestion d'un de biens communs
numérique par exemple et on a une
réflexion à mener de manière générale
sur la gestion des biens communs ça
concerne pas que le numérique d'ailleurs
et donc sur l'idée d'une entité
d'entités au pluriel international qui
gère des biens communs il ya tout un
chantier à mener et le numérique on fait
partie en effet alors à neutre à notre
niveau maintenant face aux dépendances
auxquels on fait face et au contexte
dans lequel on est donc oui on peut
utiliser la politique antitrust de bail
donne comme un tremplin clairement on
est dans une situation historique dans
un moment historique où en quelque sorte
il peut y avoir urgence inde et des
politiques dans une manière dont des
actions des poux qui nous permettrait d'
affaiblir clairement des entreprises qui
ont pris un poids un pouvoir
considérable
voilà pour ça il faut des états forts il
faut des états alors la france et
l'europe
il faut des états forts pour pouvoir en
fait lutter au niveau national et au
niveau européen on peut profiter de la
politique américaine comme d'un tremplin
ensuite je reviens sur l'idée de débat
franco français
là dessus je pense vraiment on est
plutôt dans un débat européen d'ailleurs
en 2019
le ministère de l'intérieur allemand
avait mené son enquête sur les
dépendances numérique de
l'administration allemande
ils en sont venus à la conclusion à
laquelle on peut on peut aussi aboutir
en france les soins devenu extrêmement
dépendant de microsoft dans
l'administration et que du coup ils ont
un problème de dépendance en fait
l'allemagne a fait ce constat là après
ils ont fait des choix
voilà les choix qui mène aujourd'hui à
la politique allemande est aussi à au
foie des membres de gagner
gates un peu d'intégrer par exemple est
la femme la réflexion c'est pas un
problème on peut en discuter avec mes
pieds alors pour le coup c'est européen
parce que
niveau de tous les pays d'europe toutes
les entreprises traditionnelles et l
école sont aujourd'hui face au même
problème
c'est à dire ils n'ont pas en effet de
couche logicielle développée pour les
réseaux cinq jeux par exemple
donc oui par exemple ce que disait
thomas tout à leur jeu tout à fait
d'accord avec lui l'un des problèmes
fondamentale en fait et on n'en parle
pas assez
c'est la couche logicielle des phares à
tous les niveaux par exemple on parle de
souveraineté numérique
en fait la première chose le premier
besoin auquel on a besoin de répondre
comme disait thomas cdc les sujets de
doughty du quotidien des outils de
travail des outils de l'école des petits
visioconférence ne serait-ce que la
boîte mail en fait ne pas pouvoir
choisir une boîte mail qu'ils soient
hébergés voilà en france en europe
peu importe ne pas pouvoir choisir un
prestataire en fait de pouvoir de
confiance selon nos critères
c'est un vrai problème donc le problème
de ne pas avoir d'alternative
c'est un gros souci pour vous voilà
entité internationale omi pour les biens
communs en général et pour agen alors il
nous reste que quelques minutes je vais
vous donner une minute et demie à chacun
pour donner une conclusion provisoire à
ce débat jonathan bourguignon là c'est
difficile
une ouverture tête plus qu'une
conclusion qui est que cette cette
notion de
de souveraineté numérique s'opposent en
fait fondamentalement à toute la
rhétorique qui était celle d'internet
jusque dans les années 90 telle qu'elle
était promue par des associations telles
que tel que le la l'electronic frontier
foundation qui parlait d'un qui parlait
d'un d'un cyber espace dans lequel qui
se construirait au delà de l'atteinte
des gouvernements qui construirait un
espace complètement différencier le la
légitimité de ce cyber espace en fait a
disparu pendant les 30 années qui ont
suivi est-ce qu'internet au lieu de
devenir une réalité virtuelle à côté de
la réalité qui existaient s'est mise à
recouvrir le réel facebook est allé
chercher les relations qu'on avait dans
la vraie vie pour recréer des entités
numérique et les liens entre elles et
capter ce lien social amazon a récupéré
récupérer toutes les marchandises mais
pas la créer des moyens de paiement bref
tout tout tout cet espace tout cette
promesse du cyber-espace ne s'est en
fait jamais réalisé
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya à nouveau cette
promesse du cyberespace qui est en train
de se réaliser par toute une frange très
un art show libertarienne ou pas du tout
d'ailleurs autour de l'écosystème blocs
shine ou le premier la première étape de
l'application développe shine c'était de
créer une crypto monnaie qui était
bitcoin qui en fait n'est pas vraiment
devenu une crypto menée par dessus ça il
ya eu des notions d'organisation digital
générés de manière et régis de mails
complètement automatisée par le code qui
se sont créées comme c'était insuffisant
en fait il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres écosystèmes qui sont
créés dans lesquelles le un état de
nation digital avec ddd courte des
juridiction des tribunaux sur lesquels
des utilisateurs vote et représente une
nouvelle nation sont en train de se
structurer
du coup voilà mon mot d'ouverture c'est
c'est peut-être ça que du coup il ya
toute cette toute cette question de
souveraineté numérique qui est en train
de prendre de l'ampleur depuis pas si
longtemps depuis 5 à 8 ans et
l'émergence de la chine comme comme
superpuissance technologique mais il ya
aussi il ya aussi tout un débat
transnationales qui est en train de
refaire surface
petit à petit de manière peut-être un
peu plus souterraine que ces questions
de souveraineté numérique
mais qu'il faudra suivre alors une
minute asmar balle a alors pour conclure
et aussi ouvrir un peu le sujet je pense
que il ya un problème avec la notion
d'innovation technologique je pense
qu'on a suffisamment innové que ça a été
la course à l'échalote pendant longtemps
et c'est un espèce de non-sens se passe
de l'industrialisme bizarre on court
derrière un truc sans finalité sans fin
dans une absurdité folle là où en fait
il faut commencer à peut-être décéléré
un tout petit peu et à dire mais quelle
innovation politique
on est en face donc en termes d'
instances de gouvernance je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que disait ophélie sur
la question de oui les biens communs oui
l'ouverture oui la participation
citoyenne aussi si tout le monde a bien
lu la tribune il s'agissait pas de dire
à vivre les états unis il s'agissait de
dire comment construire avec les etats
unis donc dans un corpus de valeurs
occidentales
un modèle démocratique technologique une
démocratie technologique en fait en
vérité vous avez exactement les mêmes
débats sur l'ensemble des sujets
transnationaux comme l'écologie de toute
façon un donc on ne peut pas gérer des
problématiques transfrontalières seul ou
à eux-mêmes à échelle régionale c'est
compliqué parce que c'est le monde en
fait qui est impliqué et derrière en
termes d'innovation et d'innovation
politique et je reviens à la question de
la norme et du leadership normatif c'est
aussi de se dire comment un peu dans la
continuité de sa comment est-ce qu'on
peut aujourd'hui mettre à jour une
nouvelle génération de droits de l'homme
qui associés qui est adossé à ces
technologies mais qui en fait vont aller
sur le principe de singularité le
principe d'intérêt d'under
d'indétermination pardon avec
aujourd'hui des plateformes qui sont
plutôt sur des algorithmes prédictifs du
nudge etc et qui en fait remettre un
tout petit peu bassett cette motion en
fait d'autodétermination des peuples au
centre de ses modèles technologiques
ophélie coelho une minute alors en effet
je pense qu'on a on a beaucoup de pain
sur la planche sur ces sujets là le pour
moi l'objectif
je ne sais pas mais pour à 30 ans
souhaiterait en effet de réussir à
concevoir ses modèles ces nouveaux
modèles d'entités internationale qui
pourrait agir et avoir une gestion des
biens communs ok
dans une première étape nous en ce qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui en 2021
il faut réduire les dépendances il faut
réduire les dépendances et du coup
recouvrir une forme de capacité de
négociation simplement dans parce que au
niveau aussi réguler au niveau de la
régulation européenne
par exemple on n'a pas aujourd'hui de
suffisamment de force de frappe en
quelque sorte pour pouvoir imposer aussi
nous nos envies nos règles et pour ça
c'est parce que on n'a pas assez
soutenir nos alternatives donc oui il
faut soutenir notre politique soutenue
aux politiques industrielles en faveur
de nos acteurs qui existent déjà leur
faire confiance
les aider les soutenir financièrement
quand tu en as besoin etc etc
ça ça peut passer par plein de choses
différentes on a plein d'outils en fait
un point pour faire cela donc le chemin
sera pas et pas super pour un dollar là
on a beaucoup de pain sur la planche
néanmoins on peut déjà faire beaucoup de
choses dès maintenant y'a plus qu'à y
est les derniers mots de thomas fourrure
oui pour moi là le dernier mot ce serait
un moss de conquête
je pense que la france l'europe a perdu
a perdu cet esprit de conquête qui
pourtant dans l'histoire l'a habité en
de nombreuses reprises et aujourd'hui on
est là à négocier à réfléchir comment on
pourra utiliser tel outil venant de
l'étranger etc
je pense qu'il faut retrouver cet esprit
de conquête qui est un esprit en réalité
enthousiaste il faut croire dans ce que
nous sommes capables de faire nous les
entrepreneurs français nous lé enfin
nous les les chercheurs les développeurs
les designers on est capable de créer
aussi bien il ya aucune raison mais moi
je crois que il faut que le monde
politique que les femmes et les hommes
politiques qui aujourd'hui s'engage qui
l'année prochaine vont vont soumettre
des programmes considère que le
numérique aujourd'hui envahi toute notre
vie c'est pas simplement une affaire
comme on pourrait croire ici d'experts
ya pas d'expert le numérique il est
partout et la souveraineté numérique
c'est simplement dire qu'est ce que mon
enfant va subir
qu'est-ce que moi en tant que salarié
on va m'offrir quels sont mes droits
quels sont mes libertés et simplement ce
que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il faut
faire confiance dans ce que nous sommes
dans ce que nous sommes nous européens
nos valeurs les les libertés
fondamentales
les droits de l'homme voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut faire moi c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire à toute petite échelle
et voyez déjà on arrive à avoir des
échos intéressant moi je suis quelqu'un
de très enthousiaste et et j'espère
pouvoir témoigner aussi de cet
enthousiasme auprès de nos femmes et nos
hommes politiques qu'ils puissent enfin
se saisir de ce sujet qui est un enjeu
majeur d'indépendance pour la liberté
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]